c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
remplacez mokhtar remplacer ben moctar
ben moctar j'aimerais bien garde du
corps de série ça doit être sympa je
serai plus efficace que mokhtar qui ne
pensent que lui qui a montré ses
pectoraux à la foule entière merci à
gâteau si on marque montre électoraux à
la foule en tire donc séparé de son
pareil
[Musique]
sauter en parachute avec gym je crois je
préfère parce que d'abord j'ai sauté
grâce à cyril en parachute et j'ai adoré
l'expérience
et j ai assez voilà il est très gentil
quand ils en dehors de touche pas à mon
propre histoire ultra très gentil avec
moi qui vérifiera que tout va bien il
sera aux petits oignons qua non mais les
gars moi je viens suis gentil je fais
tout bouge mais avec ce mise pour nous
répondre à vos questions vont proposer
d'autres trucs ça me fait fuir pendant
six mois votre truc
[ __ ] mais aller chercher ni chez mr
mais c'est le cosma rock punk
je pense quand même que sur une durée
aussi longue
je préfère mais ragini france maintenant
mais c'est pas possible on préfère six
mois avec marc kenis aller chez maxim
pendant un mois pourquoi pas avec un
plaisir
[Musique]